Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan,
also known as Rawkode across the Internet.
Today, we are taking a look at an
open source, painless, self hosted Gitea.
Now as always,
there are important rules. If I suddenly come
underwater,
tell me early. Do not wait till the
end of the stream. Alright? So give me
a thumbs up and a chat. Make sure
that I sound alright. And then today's session
will just be a whole lot better.
Alright. Let's pop over here. I am joined
by the project lead and founder of Gitea,
Matty. Hey, man. How's it going?
Hey. It's going really well. Thanks for having
me. Oh, it's my pleasure.
It is always the highlight of my week
when I get to sit down and take
a look at a really cool open source
project. So today, it's going to be a
whole lot of fun.
Can you please just give us a little
bit of an introduction to who you are,
please?
Of course. I'm Maddie, also known as tech
or Technologic in the Gitea community and a
broader open source community as well.
And I joined Gitea. I was looking at
my commit history just the other day, and
I joined in
2017.
The project started in
late twenty sixteen.
And
we're
just
making a way for developers to be able
to post their own source codes so they
don't have to
rely on a centralized service or
be able to self host on something as
small as a Raspberry Pi.
Awesome. Very, very cool.
Awkward timing, but the building manager was checking
my door right there. And I've also got
Russell in the chat telling me that the
sound is okay, but not amazing. Thanks,
Russell. That that's really helpful.
I'm gonna pop a cable very, very quickly.
Honestly, audio is the worst thing. I have
nothing but a hard time trying to get
right. Russell, let me know if that is
any better.
Okay. Cool. So thank you for introducing yourself
and telling us a little bit about Gitea.
It's I think it's really cool that we
have choice when it comes to hosting our
own get. It's something that I've, you know,
I've done a few times.
And it's just nice to be able to
I'm just not a complete magpie when it
comes to this stuff. Like, whenever there's a
cool open source project, I just feel the
need to, like, just go and play with
it. And Gitea has been on that list
for a while, and I haven't actually got
a run to it. So today, we're gonna
have a bit of a a centric look
at me just kinda kick the tires on
it and get started.
I also love that you said that it
runs on a a Raspberry Pi.
You know, I think we're in a really
cool age of technology where we all have
these tiny little computers set in well, mines
are mostly in drawers, but I hope other
people's aren't always sitting in drawers. But, you
know, we do have the ability to, you
know, stick in a little bit of power
in these things, sell tape them onto the
wall, and run really cool stuff at our
homes, you know, like, Gitea and Home Assistant
and all these other things. So it's cool
that that is a kind of, you know,
not a focus, but, like, it's something that
the Gitea community has embraced and adopted.
Alright. Awesome. So
you said that the Gitea project has been
around since 2016 and you joined in 2017.
I thought you were the founder, so I
made a mistake there. So Oh, sorry.
Yeah.
I I'm the project owner and
I'm a project owner and leads.
So we have, yearly elections, and I've been,
voted
for to, be the steward of the projects,
one of the three, owners, for the past
couple of years.
It's
it was a project started by, Lanny Zhao,
also known as, Lanny on GitHub.
And,
so we've been, working together for quite some
time now.
Cool.
What are some of the like, is is
there a mission statement, Rawkode? Is there, like,
something that you're just driving forward to and
pushing to? Like, you mentioned governance and elections
and stuff. I mean, that sounds like a
very mature project.
So there must be some sort of mission
statement in involved here. Yeah. Definitely. With
close to 32,000
stars, we're one of the top
500 projects on GitHub or something.
And we're
moving towards being able to actually self host
ourselves. We have the infrastructure set up. It's
just,
takes some time to extract
tens of thousands of issues and pull requests
from the GitHub ecosystem.
And so our mission statement is really just
giving
control back to developers to be able to
post the code wherever they want. And
yeah.
That's a good mission statement. I don't think
you I don't think you need much more
than that. Yeah. It's,
yeah. I have,
like, I have I get to running locally
just on my NAS, and
I have it mirroring thousands of repositories just
because
repositories
come and go and just so that I
have that archive. So then if I'm working
on something, there's
that Node. Js package from 2015 that disappeared
or whatever, and
it's there and
all of my projects still
run as expected.
Awesome.
We're we're gonna dive into the hands on
component in just a second or maybe a
a minute or two, but I wanna ask
you just a couple more questions. So
on the thumbnail for this session and on
the Gitea website, it says, like, a painless
self hosted Git solution.
Yeah. So
That's so hopefully Yeah. Sorry. Go for it.
That's
I'm I'm not gonna tempt the demo gods
today, but that is really what we strive
for that
we provide options for any technical skill level,
whether
you're a beginner or you've
been writing Linux kernels
the Linux kernel for, I guess, thirty one
years now that you can set it up
and it'll run.
Yeah.
Well, I was gonna say, I mean, it's
bold, and I like that. But I have
a I do have a natural talent for
breaking things, so I really hope that I
don't break anything today. I'm sure I won't.
Alright. Last question just because I think I've
said this publicly on Twitter before, and, like,
I feel like Git is the version control
system that we're stuck with, but not necessarily
the one we did want. And I was
curious, what are your thoughts on Git? I
mean, you must be quite
you you must work with Git literally day
in and day out. So, I mean, you
happy with it? Do you see that as
being an evolution?
While we still be using Git in five
or ten years time?
That's a very interesting question. Yeah. I've I
definitely work with Git every day,
and
it it's,
yeah. No. It's great. I love it. But
there's,
getting down into, like, the depths of things
of being able to write your own forge.
There's
some nuances that you have to be aware
of.
And I also understand that the user experience
isn't necessarily the best from command line. And
so
that's one of the problems that we're trying
to solve with Gitea is being able to
if you don't use the command line at
all, that's fine. You can do everything in
the web editor.
And we have the full, Monaco,
editor in,
the browser. Nice. And,
yeah. But I also like,
I'm I love, source control of all kinds.
I I I
I package Mercurial for NICS OS, and I
just sent a patch to Alpine just yesterday
for the update to Curio. And so I
think
yeah. No. It's it's
so fascinating,
source control because and how, different source control
systems
approach
different things. Even
and
Git have their differences, and
some people like to compare them directly. But
just even how things are stored.
Like, Git has their PAC system, and does
as well. And
Yeah.
Yeah. And I I grew up with CVS
and Subversion.
And so,
you know, Git and Curiel are a brush
a breath of fresh air.
Yeah. I do not miss
either of those two tools.
I mean, Subversion felt like such a breath
of fresh air back in the day when
we adopted it and switched it.
But, you know, the centralized model, like, it
was just very painful pushing and locking fails
and all. Yeah. Never again, hopefully.
And I I actually you know, I I
I do really, like, get my only major
gripe with it is the identity model, and
then it's literally just a text email address.
And that's it. I mean, obviously, we can
sign stuff now, and that's very cool,
but you still need that email address.
I went through a phase of just changing
my email address to, like, bell@microsoft.gov
and pushing stuff to GitHub. And, like, nothing
stops you. Right? Because why?
Cool. And lastly
on that, I experiment with a lot of
prototype
version control systems that have come out. There's
lots of them out there. Some really cool
Rust based ones that I'll try and put
the link to at the end. But then
every time I play with it for more
than ten minutes, I'm like,
I'm just wasting time now because GET is
ubiquitous. Right? Like, it's just literally everywhere. I
don't think we can get away from it
now. So
alright.
That's enough of my preferences.
I think we should dive into the hands
on component and let's get get to you
running on some on some metal.
Excellent. Let's do this. Alright.
I have my screen shared and Russell, if
you swear again in the chat, I'm gonna
ban you. Visual source safe. Come on.
May as well say Pearforce or is it
Preforce or Perforce? I can never remember.
We have the Gitea website. So if you
want to check out anything that we're doing
today,
I can remember how to zoom, you can
go to
gitea.io.
I mean, it looks familiar right off the
bat, and I'm guessing that's an intentional decision
by the team to make it familiar to
developers.
Yeah. So,
it's,
reminiscent of, GitHub,
and that's just,
the user experience is familiar with one system.
And so just transitioning over to ours is
they know where to expect things, and they
understand the concepts without having to relearn something
entirely.
Cool.
If I click on try,
this is oh, this is the test instance.
I guess I want to go to docs
for today. Right? Yeah. Cool. Exactly.
Alright. We have a whole bunch of installation
options here.
Do you have a preference?
So probably just from binary
is
likely the
is one of the most common
ways.
Just download the binary from our
release site and
Yeah. Hit the ground running. Well, before I
I do that then, you know,
Gitea is written in Go. Right? Is that
right?
That's right. Yeah. And then we have our
presentation layer is a combination of
some Node. Js packages and
UCSS frameworks.
Okay. Cool.
Awesome.
Because I haven't I have tried to install,
you know, GitLab is obviously an open source
Git solutions as well.
But that was the most painful week of
my life, I think, trying to
it's multiple services, but really they're distributed as,
like, one big massive thing. Yeah.
I lost some sleep that week for sure.
That's interesting that you say that because that's
actually how I came to Gitea as well
is
I was responsible for managing GitLab and
no shade to them because they've done wonderful
things with their installer. It's just
the omnibus now. But
at that time, it was I was looking
for alternatives.
And,
yeah, I found Gitea, and my life has
changed for the better since.
Yeah. I I love that you mentioned the
omnibus because back in the day when I
I'd I'd talked to Kubernetes
really early,
and one of the first things I tried
to deploy to it was our own GitLab
instance for the organization I was working for
at the time and the Omnibus Helm chart
that just deployed everything. And I was like,
how do I, like, upgrade one component? And
the answer was just like, no. You don't.
And I'm like, alright.
So this thing's shipping Postgres and Redis and
14 Ruby applications as this. Yeah.
I should have the toys at the prom
and just walked away.
But we're not gonna have that problem today.
So what have I prepared in advance? Well,
nothing as always the answer. We have a
oh, my shells kicked me off. Alright.
Hopefully, that's the same IP address. Nice.
We have Equinix metal, bare metal machine. We've
got some cores. We've got some RAM. I
haven't done anything to this. This is a
Ubuntu box. It's a vanilla Ubuntu install. There's
nothing special done here in advance.
So we're gonna go through the process of
installing Gitea on this machine. And I'm really
hoping that Matt is not gonna shut around
and go, oh, Ubuntu. Sorry. Not today.
Ubuntu is gonna be okay. Right?
It's gonna be definitely great. And just as
a disclaimer from our side, Equinix is a
sponsor of the project.
Oh, are they? But Oh, nice. We recommend
them otherwise
even if they didn't sponsor us.
I I actually used to work for Equinix
Bell, so I do have access to the
machines.
And I use them for everything because they're
just they're fantastic. Why spin up a VM
with one core and 512 mega RAM when
you could just spin up a monster machine
and get so much more done?
Exactly. Yeah. Okay.
So I didn't know that, but that's very
cool that they sponsored the project.
Alright. Let's work through this then. So we're
gonna download the right file. This is AMD
sixty four.
This is gonna be really easy, isn't it?
I mean,
I'm assuming I could probably just run Gitea
help. Yeah. There we go.
So
is this is one of the really special
things about Go as well. And I'm not
a daily Go developer. I do typically prefer
to write things in Rust, but the static
compilation of Go binaries and the ability to
ship them everywhere is very, very nice. I've
got to say.
I mean, is that as done?
Did I just run Gitea?
Yeah.
I mean, you could,
but it's recommended to use a separate Unix
user just because it
if you're running with open SSHD,
it will take over your authorized key files.
So there's a bunch of copy and paste
things that you can do to create the,
new,
Git user. And then also just general,
if you're pushing and pulling via SSH, you
don't want root at
gitt.com.
You want to get gitt.com.
Yeah. That makes a lot of sense.
I guess what I'm curious about right now
is that you mentioned that there's Gitea,
which is a server. It's written in Go.
You have a front end, which has other
components. I'm assuming there's a database that needs
to be configured or used in some capacity.
So,
like, does this all ship in a single
binary?
Yeah. So
everything's precompiled,
you can use SQLite.
If you have
database already or if you wanna configure a
database as well,
you can do that, MySQL, Postgres,
MS SQL, if you're a Windows shop.
But if
you're just a lone developer,
SQLite is will meet your needs more than
enough.
Yeah. I'm I try to encourage people to
use SQLite a lot more, especially with what
Ben Johnson's doing now at fly.io
with LightStream and the ability to kinda, like,
hook into the rate ahead log and rate
it to blob storage. It's just absolutely
ridiculous what you can do now with SQLite.
I I actually find myself struggling to reach
for post queries anymore, which was always my
default.
Okay.
Well, this is really cool. Single binary stuff
makes me happy, especially from an operational point
of view.
What about other deployment models?
I couldn't look at the website here, but
if I wanna run this in a Kubernetes
cluster
And we have a Helm chart exactly for
that. So you can install the Helm chart,
and it comes with, optional dependencies,
the, Bitnami
database
charts if you,
want to, use them to spin up a
database.
But, again, it's optional. So if you already
have a database cluster set up, you can
point to that. Or,
if you
we don't recommend running the SQLite on Kubernetes
just because, likely, you're
mounting the files from other NFS or
whatnot.
So the latency there would be, something to
worry about, but, you know, it's possible.
K. Cool.
Alright. Well, I'm gonna run through your recommended
server configuration then.
I don't even know if get ships by
default.
It does. Okay. Nice.
And next, we're gonna add the get user.
Like you said, we don't wanna be doing
root at. So let's grab this.
It's just setting up bash and disable the
password.
And I'm assuming all the repositories within the
Gitea instance Gitea and Gitea
Gitea and
live in home get. They're just gonna be
thrown in there. Is that right? That's exactly.
Actually, in the next set of commands, you'll
see
that it's I'm gonna store it all in
bare lib Gitea. Alright. Okay.
Alright. Let's do that.
And then we chill on some stuff.
But we don't have an any further yet.
Right?
Oh, yes. So if you
the installer
will auto create it for you.
So when you, set up Gitea the first
time,
installer will be presented to you, or you
can, hand create the configuration
file yourself.
Okay. I haven't seen any mention of an
installer yet. Did I skip a step?
No.
So that's that's good to know to include
that.
Alright. Let's just skip
over that just now.
So
then
yeah. I really need to stop scamming stuff
and read things properly. Do I need to
run git generate secret?
So that will if you're manually generating the
configuration file, then you'll need to. But otherwise,
the installer will create that for you.
Alrighty.
So let's set the work there.
Copy this to Ben.
And now we get to decide how to
manage
this.
So this is just to run it, but
we can use our Linux service. So
let's do it the nice way.
I like it when software gives me a
system d unit fail. It makes me very
happy.
Service.
Oh, yeah. I'll fix that.
So this is set up with all the
defaults that we've just worked on, which is
the user
get. Yep. And the group. We didn't add
a group get that we I'll need to
add that.
Working directory looks okay.
And
we don't need a database dependency.
I think that's fine
except for my name because I can't type
service
enum
reload.
Okay.
What do you think? That should I add
that group, or do you think we'll be
okay?
Probably best to add that group, actually.
We have one of our maintainers,
John, in the chat, and
he's taking notes.
Group ad.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, I guess the ad user would have
created it. Oh, fantastic. Did it have a
flag on it? Oh, it did. Okay. Dash
dash group. Okay. Fantastic.
Awesome.
So we could then run the enable,
I'm assuming.
Tada.
There we go.
Alright. I don't need your docs anymore.
So
let's grab
the IP address, which I don't remember, so
I'll grab from here.
And
it doesn't run on port 80.
Yeah. It's not a a privileged
process, and so it can't listen to anything
below
or sorry, ten twenty four.
By default,
the port is 3,000.
Cool.
So
we've got it running
with ease.
I mean, let's just call it ease because
all I did was done with a pain.
We're sticking it our training how to get
a file. So this is pretty sweet.
Now I've got a web interface to configure
this, but I'm assuming this is just for
ease of use. Right? This is part of
your painless mission. If I wanted to, I
could write that any file and probably skip
this step altogether. Is that Exactly.
In our Docker file, we have
a series of environment variables that will actually
it'll take those environment variables and generate the
app config based on that.
And similarly, in our helm chart, we have
an init scripts that will do something similar.
So you can just define it all in
your values dot YAML.
Cool.
Let me scan this.
I'm not gonna configure email. Is that okay?
Yes. That will only be needed if for,
like, password resets or
to get notified of, new pull request.
What if the
that's because we didn't change the permissions because
it doesn't exist. But if I just do
a
app.ini
change owner.
Oh, and the install page will also create
you can create an administrator user through here,
or you can also create it
via the
it's just the first user that will register.
Oh.
Oh, dear.
See if it's still running.
K. It's running
as like working. Log is showing up.
I think it just should it restart when
I put the install?
Yeah. But the listener should be still going.
Alright.
Let's try
a little bit of encouragement.
Oh, wait. It's redirected me to the cohost.
That's right.
Because,
it'll redirect you to the root URL,
and by default, it's local host. I see.
Yeah. It's good. So this will be a
warning scene.
There's a difference.
It's actually a warning. See, if I pay
attention to the error messages, I'd have less
problem. So
I'm assuming that was part of that form
that I very quickly just failed on Rawkode
Academy and disappeared. So
That's exactly it. Yeah. So if you just
change
finder and place local host all over to
the IP,
then
So I'm There you go. Using an IP
right now. Right? So I'm assuming for most
people, they're gonna want some sort of
DNS entry here.
Does Exactly. He
do the let's encrypt that for us, or
do we handle that externally?
We can do the let's encrypt ourselves.
Although,
you would need to set the binary
some the privileged Linux permissions to be able
to listen on port eighty and four four
three.
But,
you know, you could run something like KADI
in front and other wonderful Go projects. Mhmm.
NGINX, Apache,
any
proxy even.
What does your setup look like for your
own Gitea instances?
So we, run,
we provide the privileged,
board access,
just because it's,
yeah.
But,
yeah, let's encrypt works great. We actually also
use the caddy
library
for
working with let's encrypt.
And I was assuming by privilege, what you
mean is modifying
this unit fail.
Yeah. System.
And add another net CAP net raw or
CAP net bank service
capability.
Right?
Yeah. I think that's the one.
CAP
net bank.
Yeah. That's the one for getting port 80.
Yeah.
We have it documented somewhere in our documentation.
So if you search for it
in our docs as well,
it should be somewhere there.
I don't know what to search for. 80.
Yeah. Let's try AT.
Alright. So, yep, this ACME lets encrypt support,
username,
or you can do okay. So you've documented
the proxies as well.
Okay.
I don't see the privileged guide, but maybe
it's in there somewhere.
Not a big deal for today.
So let's jump back
and now our error has gone.
So this is the fresh Gitea instance then.
Right?
Yeah. So you can create your first account
and that will become the administrative
user.
I mean, this is instance isn't gonna live
long, so I don't mind everybody seeing what
that password is for the for the next
thirty minutes.
These are all very trustworthy, I hope.
Cool. So do we get, like,
let's say admin. That's what I was gonna
say. Like, the ability to tweak and configure
things within the Gitea instance. So
most of the configuration is done via the
app config just so that you can script
deployments.
But there's a
maintenance operations task as you can see right
here to,
clean up things and, test your configuration.
Mhmm.
Does Gitea have LFS
support?
Does.
Nice. Yeah.
Yeah.
And we recently had a major release
within the past month where we also added
support for
packages of all sorts. So
Python
packages,
Ruby gems,
Docker containers, Helm charts,
so many things. And
yeah. So we're very excited about that functionality
specifically.
Okay.
I'm just clicking buttons now. Hope that's alright.
Yeah.
Of course.
Template.
Label.
What license is Gitea?
We're licensed MIT.
Yeah. I use MIT for just pretty much
everything there.
Okay.
So I've created the Git repository. In fact,
I've a few things there while we were
kind of chatting.
I created an organization,
which I guess might come up under explore.
Yeah.
And I could create something here, which is
cool. I created at my own repository
and we got a license and a read
me.
I guess what we wanna do is get
to the step where I can actually pull
this down.
So I'm assuming if I
could just add my SSH key
to my settings.
Oh, you support signing commits too with GPG?
Yeah. Signing commits with GPG
as well as
in January, reintroduced
signing commits with your SSH key.
Nice. I actually used I have one password
that I configured with both my with my
SSH keys, which I can use for signing.
Although, I have been exploring
cosign from the the chain guard folks. I
don't know if you've been talking to them
about verifying their signatures, but those are pretty
cool as well because they use OIDC
against
Google, etcetera.
Alright.
One password was trying to be nice there
and now it's changed its mind.
Yeah. We'll create a new one.
Cool.
Alright. Let's do the test. Are you feeling
confident?
I am, yes.
Alright.
So we are doing a git clone from
our instance.
Well, let's ask for my key so it's
gonna work.
Hey.
There we go.
Yeah. You know what? I'm gonna give you
the painless. I can't take that away from
the project. Like, I mean, we we've done
a lot there and relatively no time or
effort whatsoever.
And already, I'm able to clone down our
repository and start working on it. So that's
pretty sweet. Very cool.
Mozz asked in the chat, is Gitea written
in Go? Yeah. You joined a little bit
late, but we did cover it. It's written
in Go, but there is the front end
which has
I think you said some react stuff going
on there.
I've I've view JS. Oh, view JS. Yeah.
And
we use
semantic
CSS framework, which is a fork of semantic
CSS.
John is saying don't forget to change this
to the dark theme.
Rawkode agreeing that was pretty easy.
Cool.
We have a question from Miles.
Does Gitea support token based authentication
instead of passwords?
We do. And in fact,
we're working towards
slowly deprecating,
utilizing your user's password
to
in your clone actions or API calls.
There's token based API.
There's,
app tokens available currently.
It is it is possible to use your
user's password,
but not recommended. And, eventually, it'll be going
away
just because you shouldn't be using your password
just everywhere.
Yeah. Well, I do see the option here
to use web off end, which is awesome.
But because we're on look there we're not
on local, but
It's specifically
It's it's TLS. It's HTTPS.
Yeah.
So that
error should get updated as well. But you
also support two factor authentication
and there's open ID as well. You can
do delegation to,
I guess, to Google, etcetera.
Yeah. So we have
OpenID
that you can log in as. But as
an administrator, you're also able to set up
other authentication
sources. So if you wanna have users log
in with their GitHub account, their GitLab account,
their Twitter,
we have a whole bunch. I think you
can even log in with, Discord is one
of the ones that was the last ones
that I added.
Cool.
Alright. I'm gonna just gonna stop clicking on
buttons. Is
there anything
that you think would be interesting
to take a look at
from the Gitea instance that we set up.
Yeah. So
you showed how to
create a new repository,
but one of
one of the things that we're
very excited about is our migration capabilities.
So
rather than
if you wanna migrate away from GitHub or
something,
you can create a new migration, throw in
your Git URL, and it will do the
Git clone itself. So you don't need to
do that step.
But then you can also
if you wanna get advanced, you can also
throw in
your
GitHub app token, and it'll actually clone over
issues from that repository as well and pull
request.
And
so you can fully set up.
So that's
pull mirrors, but then we also have push
mirrors.
So you can work with your repository locally
with your local Gitea instance, and then you
can have it pushed to various remotes
itself.
Yeah.
Alright. Will we test this?
Pop in any
Git repository.
Okay.
Well, this is the meta support. So this
just means
I guess I would have to provide the
access token for that, or do I always
have to provide an access token? So
if you're mirroring it, it will just do
a git clone. You'll need to provide the
access token if it's a private repository.
However, if you're going to migrate labels,
pull request, milestones, you'll need to provide auth
because
just
otherwise,
the experience of
getting rate limited for, like, 50 queries from
the GitHub API is not pleasant, and it
will take a week to migrate anything.
There you go. Holy shit.
That was fast.
And it pulls in the
project description as well,
full history.
And
Hand on my yeah.
Yeah.
So in terms of CI integration right now,
there's a question in chat from Rio.
We
have integration with
a bunch of different CI providers,
Jenkins,
Drone, Woodpecker,
to name a few.
The project itself, we use Drone
primarily just because,
in the beginning of our project, we had
a lot of overlap between contributors to drone
as well as,
Gitea.
However,
now
a Woodpecker is a fork of drone, and
that's where mainly the Gitea contributors are at
now.
Okay.
But it can report
statuses
back to commit. So just like on GitHub,
you can see the
check mark if you're build on a specific
commit was successful.
In pull request, you can see,
again,
your various different external
CI providers
work out.
You can do branch protection
based on CI status.
So
don't merge that pull request if the tests
fail.
Very cool.
I get an RSS feed as well from
I guess if I start pushing to this,
does that publish new things to the feed?
That will. Yeah. So it's not
every commit.
Excuse me. It's
that's specifically
for releases.
Ah, okay. Yeah.
Alright. Let's cut a release.
I've been meaning to do one point o
for a leak the last nine months, so
why why not do it here?
0.1.
So let's make sure my assumptions are correct
in that case for the new assessment. Yeah.
And if I use the I'm just gonna
test it. So
okay. Let me throw a a question out
then. There's there's a lot of similarities here
between Gitea and GitHub, and we discussed that
at the start about how it's supposed to
be familiar so that people, you know, they're
not discouraged or intimidated or anything like that.
Would you say Gitea has pretty good parity
with what GitHub offers?
Because it it looks and feels like it.
I I mean, I haven't visually seen anything
that isn't
on Gitea here.
Yeah. So in our docs, we have a
a whole long comparison document
that lists out the differences between,
Gitea, Gogs,
GitLab, and, GitHub.
And,
for the most part, there's a lot of,
overlap.
And one of our actually,
I mentioned SSH signing.
We had that in January, but, Giteaub just
released that fairly recently. So in,
some cases, we're,
moving faster.
We're not a multibillion dollar company, so but,
you know, we still have some agility.
Well, who who prioritizes
the work then? I mean, I've I've an
open source project. This is a very common
problem. Right? Is that everybody wants to work
on the thing that's most important to them,
and this can be difficult to find direction.
But I'm assuming, again, come back to what
you said at the start of it, there
being, like, governance and such. So you must
be quite a well oiled machine to a
certain point. I am assuming you just know
what that road map looks like.
Yeah.
As we're all volunteers right now,
it is working on,
what,
we all
want to work on.
Although,
there's,
maintainers
and
core contributors, we all, also contribute,
like,
minor
refactors for stability enhancements,
as well as,
like,
like, bug fixes and whatnot. So,
it's a nice mix of, features as well
as,
stability
resolutions.
A question from chat.
Gitea
does
somewhat support clustering.
We previously on Gitea.com,
we were running Gitea in a
multicluster
setup or a multinode setup.
Although,
right now,
there's instances of Gitea with tens of thousands
of users running on a single machine. So
the need for high availability
is
like, you'll need to question,
like
like,
whether or not you do actually need it.
Well, yeah, whether they want it for scale
or whether they want it for redundant. Yeah.
I mean, if it's for scale Yeah. You
probably don't need to. I mean, we have
these numbers at the bottom, which I keep.
To catch my eye every time I load
a new page. But the there have never
been more than a few milliseconds for any
of these pages. Yeah. And I know this
is an empty instance, but, you know, is
that when you get to the larger instances,
I'm assuming these I'm hoping these numbers still
stay pretty small.
They definitely do. And,
one of our, other owners,
Zary Path, he's put in a ton of
effort into keeping,
that performance of being able to browse, like,
even the Linux kernel with
all of its commits, just keeping it speedy.
Just keeping it down low. And just for
sake of comparison,
gt.com,
we have, I think, something like 30,000,
registered users,
and even more repositories.
And we have four gigs of RAM on
that server.
Now,
our storage is rather significant. We have
I think it's a a terabyte of storage,
right now reserved, and,
we can scale that up because we're on
a cloud provider.
Just click and drag the
storage bar for our NFS server.
But,
you know, like I said at the beginning,
our
we really aim to have
just as little resources as possible
used.
Thanks.
Well, while you were talking about cluster and
high availability, I was playing with your project
feature and just threw
on some boards. I like that I can
color them. Got an issue. I mean,
this is really cool. I mean, I'm just
dragging stuff about there, but I like it.
I'm gonna close this now. This is where
I fixed it. There we go.
Alright. So we oh, we were gonna test
your release RSS. That's what it was.
Hey.
Look at that. Alright. So we get issues.
My release as well. Cool. Okay. So,
yeah, these are actions that have taken place
in the repository,
not just releases.
So same thing that happens in your,
your explore feed on the home page.
It will show that you've created issues, closures,
issues.
So this
is the information that will show up in
the RSS feed, except it'll be filtered per
that
Cool. Specific repository. Alright.
Nice. I mean, I don't think I've ever
seen RSS feeds from another Git provider. But,
I mean, I still use RSS daily, like,
for everything, for all my news and stuff
like that. Like, why would I not wanna
subscribe to, like, the most important project and
get update?
Exactly. So GitHub does have RSS feeds
if I can
promote another project.
They just don't have the it visible. But
if you go view source, you can view
their atom links. Ah,
had no idea.
But that was one of the first things
I noticed when I was on this thing.
Was like, oh, look. They got this. So
it's amazing how you just stick an icon
on something, and it actually becomes a whole
lot more visible to people.
Okay.
We've kinda covered
that Gitea
has a level of parity with GitHub. It's
got a couple of extra features. We've seen
the migration support there. Is there anything else
that's different in Gitea that you wanna highlight
as part of our our session?
Nothing.
I think I think we've covered everything I
wanted to focus on today.
Awesome.
Alright. Well, I'm gonna ask you a question
then.
So Yeah. Definitely.
I have a lot of repositories
on GitHub
and
yeah. 306.
Now, of course, most of them are crappy
one time Forex and stuff like that, but
but they they add up. And I've always
wanted to be able to group some together,
and GitLab does offer, like, grouping support. Is
that something that you've talked discussed
Gitea, and is that something that you think
you would implement?
Yeah. So there is a ticket open for
subgroups.
But just like with GitHub,
we have, labels.
You can also filter based on labels to
be able to categorize.
Say if you're working for a company and
you have your
infrastructure's
code repositories
and then you have your application code, you
can take stuff as IAC
and filter based on that, or
you can,
take stuff as application code and filter based
on that for your specific
team
repositories.
John
is in the chat mentioning a visual swagger
UI.
Yeah. If you scroll down to the bottom
of the page,
there should be a link to the API,
and that's what, John's talking about.
So we have,
an API,
and so this is actually
programmatically generated
from our API endpoints.
And so
you can
see all of the endpoints that are available.
You can test the endpoints.
And we also have,
a command line tool that will work with
the API as well called,
t.
So if you don't wanna use the
web interface, you can use the CLI and
create pull request, browse issues.
Alright. I don't don't mean to break stuff
intentionally that time. Oh, cool. So you could
just can use it straight from in the
so I got you.
Cool.
And you mentioned that command line application as
well?
Yeah. So
gitea.com/gitea/t,
and
you can install it.
If you're on a Mac, you can use
our homebrew tab.
T the letter or t the
I don't
know.
Oh, Gitea.com
rather.
Comt.
Nope.
Slash Gitea/t.
Yeah.
There we go.
There's a nice public instance that's available to
anyone?
It is public. The primary focus of it
is to
the
for the purpose of building Gitea,
although there are non Gitea related repositories
on there.
But,
generally, we recommend,
right now,
codeberg.org.
They're a
Gitea instance
primarily focused on
free and open source software.
And
a disclaimer,
I'm on the Presidium of that organization.
Right.
So this is a green tick.
Oh, yeah. We've got checks here.
So what's this hooked up to?
So this is hooked up to our drone
instance. And
so you can see
all of the tests that it runs. And
so, yeah, this is a perfect example of
external CI.
So in a bit yeah. Nice.
I'm stuck. There we go.
Awesome.
I should've came here earlier. I'm seeing loads
of cool things now. So is that you
also support issue templates as well?
Yep.
Issue templates,
you can
we just merged
the
custom issue forms.
Like,
on GitHub, you can say,
please fill out the version number of the,
of what you're using and having it required
so that,
users don't just, skip optional elements in or
required elements in the form. You can say,
fill out the version number
and other interesting things like that.
Great.
Alright.
Have we covered everything? Will I put this
back into, like, face mode?
Yeah. Let's go back into face mode.
So that's really cool. Gitea is a a
really cool project.
Super simple to set up. I mean, literally,
pull out a binary down, tell us next
machine and just I mean, I could've just
ran it straight away, you know, set up
a system to unit files seems like the
nicer approach. And again, it took us a
few seconds
and everything just kinda worked.
I love that I can use SQLite.
You know, I definitely would hook that up
to Lightstream and start replicating that to GCS
probably,
pulling that down to give me some sort
of redundancy or resiliency.
Just a really cool
system.
Great work. Like
Thank you. Yeah. It's
thousand plus
people have contributed to the project, so it's
it's a real community effort, and it takes
a village.
Well, how about
like, say people watch this and they think,
I'd love to get involved. Like, what what's
the best avenue for them to reach out,
to start discussions,
and to start writing code if they want?
Yeah. So, in terms of reaching out, we
have our various chat channels. Discord and are
bridged together.
And and you can come into the developed
channel saying, hey. I wanna get started.
And there are a ton of people,
who are very happy to help there. That's
several of our core maintainers started out that
way with no go experience, and now they
write go every day.
And we also have a bunch of,
issues labeled good first issue of
improving the docs or,
things to get,
your feet wet with experiencing the code base.
And we also, participate in Oktoberfest every year,
run events. I've
last year, I livestreamed
over Twitch.tv.
As you mentioned, links will be down below.
And
this year, I'm actually, gonna try to do
some,
really interesting projects.
So we saw one instance of Gitea running
on Equinix metal,
but I'm gonna try something.
How many instances of Gitea can we run
on a single server?
Because
our RAM resources are extremely low, so let's
pop open one of those
super beefy ones or MacConnex, and
how many can we run?
I did a a stream
on Wednesday,
and
I used them at
you know, it's the back machine we're using
today, but it's it's the modest one on
Equinix metal. And they have these new machines
called the a thief,
and it had a
terabyte of RAM
and
a 28
cores, I think it was.
And I was like, I wonder if you
like, if you're gonna do that test, you
should get one of those and then see
how many Giteaus you can run on that
thing because I would imagine it's a hell
of a lot, especially with that RAM footprint
as well.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Alright. Any
last words before we we finish up today?
No. I just thank you for having me.
Thank you everyone in chat for joining us
on this journey. And,
yeah,
please,
reach out, if you wanna get involved or
if you wanna set up your own instance
and you have any questions.
If you wanna go above and beyond what
we did today, set up a package registry,
you can hook it into
s three if you wanna store your packages
up there, your Docker containers, your Ruby gems.
If you wanna enable code search,
hook into Elasticsearch.
And you mentioned,
authentication
with,
or verification
cosign.
But we also,
can hook into,
things such as,
small step for
being able to authenticate with an SSH principle
and similar
concept.
And so I'm
gonna be working on blog posts for all
these more advanced topics, so follow us on
our blog. Yeah.
And all of our links are down below.
Yes. I will make sure all the links
are there shortly after we finish up here
today.
And also, I didn't I did click on
the package thing as well while we were
chatting, and I forgot to actually talk about
it. But you said that there's an OCI
compatible
store as well. Do you do NPM, PyPI,
stuff like that?
Exactly. All of that. Yeah.
Nice. Any
we just
that was released in 01/17,
and in 01/18,
we're still adding even more, like,
Vagrant
packages.
Vagrant boxes was just added.
Wow. Awesome.
Alright. Well, thank you so much for joining
me today. It's been a pleasure. Very, very
cool projects. Lots of links will be in
the show notes, and we will see you
all again next time. Thank you for watching.
Have a nice day.